نظرًا لأن أوروبا تعيد فتح العديد من حدودها
وتأمل الخطوط الجوية في استعادة بعض
الأعمال في تسجيل وصول لوفتهانزا في فرانكفورت ،
فمن الواضح أن الكثير قد تغير بالطبع ، فإن
الحفاظ على المسافة الفعلية يكاد
يكون مستحيلًا عندما تكون في
رحلة جوية دولية
ولهذا السبب لوفتهانزا والعديد من الآخرين
تتبع شركات الطيران سياسة مطالبة جميع
ركابها بارتداء أقنعة في كل
من المطار وعلى متن الطائرة داخل
مبنى الركاب ، والكثير من إجراءات التباعد الجسدي ،
ولكن عند الصعود على متن الطائرة لا مزيد
من المتعقب ، يوزع أكان
مناديل مطهرة ، لكن بخلاف ذلك يقول
الركاب لا يفعلون ذلك.  لا داعي لتغيير
سلوكهم كثيرًا ، الشيء الوحيد الذي نطلبه من
المقامرون أن يرتدوا القناع
طوال الوقت فقط إذا شربوا أو أكلوا
شيئًا يمكنهم خلعه مثل العديد من
شركات الطيران الأوروبية ، معظم أسطول لوفتهانزا
لا يزال خاملاً منذ
تفشي فيروس كورونا  حصلت الشركة مؤخرًا
على خطة إنقاذ بحوالي 10 مليارات
دولار لمساعدتها على النجاة من الأزمة ،
لكن رحلتنا من فرانكفورت إلى بورتو
هي حزمة.  كما ترى ، نحن جميعًا
نجلس قريبًا جدًا من بعضنا البعض وهذه
إحدى المعضلات التي تواجهها شركات الطيران مثل
Lufthansa ولكن العديد من الشركات الأخرى واجهت جيدًا
من ناحية أنها تحتاج إلى مفهوم النظافة
الذي يعمل ولكن يجب أيضًا
إقناع المسافرين المرهقين بأن  من الآمن
العودة إلى الطائرات مرة أخرى ، بعض
المسافرين قلقون بعض الشيء من
أنه مخيف بعض الشيء على ما أعتقد
لأنك لا تعرف أبدًا ما الذي قد
يصيبك به كثيرًا ، فأنا
متفاجئ قليلاً لأنني قاتلت في الواقع
بناءً على فيروس كورونا الذي نجلس عليه
تقول شركة Lufthansa القريبة جدًا إن
فلاتر الهواء الحديثة على
الطائرات تجعل العدوى من غير المحتمل أن تكون
الأدوية آمنة ، حيث إن أكثر من 99 ٪ من
تلك الفيروسات سيأخذها
الآخرون ، حيث يتعين على الطيارين
ارتداء الأقنعة دائمًا.  على الأرض
ولكن ليس في الهواء أبدًا ، يقول القبطان
إنه وجه ، إن التعبيرات مهمة جدًا
إذا تواصلت مع
زميلك الذي تعرفه
ولديك موقف غريب من الجيد أن
ترى أنه يخشى أن يكون  قبل الهبوط في
البرتغال ، قام الطاقم بتوزيع منشورات حول
كيفية الوقاية من العدوى حيث
تحاول شركات الطيران إقناع المسافرين بأن
السفر الجوي للعطلات ممكن دون المخاطرة بحدوث
ارتفاعات جديدة وعدوى فيروس كورونا.